merci patricia avec nous donc juliette
binoche pour un film signé de leos carax
alors on vous parlera dans un instant
avec julie à de ce monsieur leos carax
qui signe là son deuxième film ça
s'appelle mauvais sens c'est avec michel
piccoli et vous avez déjà expliqué à
notre ami pierre tchernia que c'était un
film un rat comptable mais c'est
difficile de parler de quelque chose que
l'on situe pas alors je vais essayé de
situer que vous me dire si je commets
des erreurs
alors c'est une histoire d'amour il ya
trois personnages et michel piccoli ya
juliette c'est vous et puis denis lavant
à d'autres comédiens mais enfin de là
l'histoire d'amour c'est entre vous 3
plutôt humble alors c'est un amour qui
est très très fort et qui peut être
symbolisée par le fait qu'ils veulent
tous avec une bande de truands conquérir
écoutez bien conquérir le vaccin qui
guérirait d'une terrible maladie qui tue
les amants qui font l'amour sans amour
bon alors je vous en raconte pas plus je
trouve que cette idée est belle et c'est
surtout un film d'atmosphère qui s'est
déroulé dans des circonstances de les
conditions très particulières
quelles conditions qu'est ce qui vous a
obligé à faire ce metteur en scène et
comme une aventure on partait ensemble
dans sur le même bateau et petit à petit
vont les
disons que le tournage c'est devenu plus
long quoi dans le temps mais c'était
c'était nécessaire au film mais déçoit
vraiment de d'être le fer le plus beau
et le plus long voyage
oui mais ça c'est pas la prendre
n'importe quel film or il vous a
maintenant raconté enfermé dans un hôtel
qui vous a fait dire désormais viser au
moins aussi vous a fait lire des textes
voulez pas vous rentrez chez vous
pourquoi voulez vous restez c'est moi
qui voulais pas besoin on est et on
était
on était 2000 avant les os et moi on
était ensemble dans dans un hôtel on
pouvait se voir le soir et et disons ce
lié encore plus quoi il se concentrer
encore plus sur sur ce qu'on devait
faire mieux
oui il y avait un grand décor qu'on a
construit deux qui était une grande rue
de saintes 200 mètres de long et il
fallait dans cet espace créé quelque
chose de magique et c'est surtout un
film d'émotion un film de davanture
aussi mais d'émotions vous ne vous
parlerai tout à l'heure l'aventuré
l'émotion pourquoi elle peut être
procurés par par ce monsieur leos carax
en avoir quelques images de mauvais sens
c'est d'une bagarre à la crème à raser
figurez-vous entre juliette binoche et
son partenaire l'un de ses partenaires
oui
est-ce que vous connaissiez ce monsieur
car access que c'était quelqu'un qui
tombe d'une manière classique où il vous
a surpris
heureusement qui m'assurent précisant je
vais pas tourner avec les j'avais vu son
film son premier film qui était bon et
mister et et puis on est pillé un
contact tout de suite on a eu envie de
te faire léger j'ai l'impression que ray
me dire c'est je découvre quelque chose
mais que vous aimez beaucoup ce film
c'est pas toujours le cas quand un
comédien tourne un film qui impression
vous êtes encore émergé comme ces
messieurs vous êtes toujours quand je
n'ai pas vu beaucoup mais quand je le
vois chaque fois je suis je suis étonné
parce qu'il ya des périodes tellement
différent des moments tellement
différent de et des moments de suspense
de peur et puis et des moments de espèce
de fascination d'émotion qui qui qui
s'est pas appuyé de ses différences de
température aussi il est très très chaud
ou un moment et on tournait en tournée
en pull en hiver et pillé des eaux
moment il faisait moins qu'un cet hiver
ont tourné en manche en manches courtes
et c'était c'était il y avait des
difficultés physiques disons enfin
n'hésitez pas tous les jours facile mais
mais il y avait comme une entre les
comédiens metteurs en scène le chef
opérateur et puis les gens de la
technique
oui avait il y avait comme une magie
d'abord j'espère que ça traduit sur sur
l'image
en tout cas sachez que c'est dans un
quart d'heure si vous voulez tout de
suite aller voir ce film
merci de votre visite vous avez bien
supporté le poids de la pression du
césar camy si vous avez dans le meilleur
espoir même 100 millions l'étaient pas
voir 84ème blanche est content et j'ai
confondu avec une une très jolie voilà
les mauvaises informations que l'on me
donne on va aller à la bourse